qu'on veut faire c'est justin c'est con
à partie un service à l'achat alors à
sainte justine
les patients sont comme l auteur ils ont
un menu à la chambre alors il commande
quand ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent mais
au bout du compte malgré le fait que le
patient choisit c'est toujours une
technicienne en tête-- technique
irresponsable de prendre la pelle et
s'assurer que ce que le patient le
demande répond vraiment à ses besoins de
tous élèves en temps réel pour chacun si
geoffrey ce matin un petit déjeuner de
la cafétéria d'un hôpital peut-être bien
que vous me diriez non merci et je vais
aller manger ailleurs et disons que la
bouffe d'hôpital vous le savez sapin
vraiment bonne réputation mais ce matin
vous allez peut-être surpris d'apprendre
que c'est différent au chu
sainte-justine apparemment bien
appétissant avec moi josée lavoie chef
de service et des psycho justin justin
madame lavoie bonjour bonjour vous avez
d'ailleurs reçu un prix d'excellence
hier soir pour la personnalisation des
services de votre cafétéria à l'hôpital
au chu sainte justine
effectivement le délit papc le nom de
notre service alimentaire à sainte
justine a reçu effectivement le plus
personnalisation qu'est ce que vous
faites deux sites différents à sainte
justine
alors écoutez noise indus ce temps ce
qui est important pour nous c'est de
pouvoir humanisé et redonner le contrôle
aux patients de son alimentation
alors les patients ont un menu à la
chambre est de 6 heures 30 à 19 heures
le soir le patient la possibilité de
pouvoir commander les aliments qui le
souhaitent donc la quantité et les choix
alimentaires qu'ils soient de faire donc
c'est vraiment une carte repos qui est
ouverte
donc c'est comme au restaurant
finalement les petits patients se
trouvent dans leur chambre et reçoivent
pas de n'importe quel plateau qui sont
distribués à tous les tous les patients
même temps sinon c'était tellement chaud
oui le passé en mange alors qu'ils le
souhaitent et selon le niveau d'appétit
kg alors ce changement a permis chez
nous de réduire énormément le gaspillage
avant de faire ce virage là il y avait
25 % des assiettes qui était redescendu
à la cuisine un touché maintenant on a 5
% du plateau en totalité qui est jeté
donc pour nous c'était un immense gains
étant donné que le patient consomme
exactement ce qu'il ce qu'ils souhaitent
finale dont vous avez rêvé
oui le gaspillage alimentaire énormément
importante et augmenter la satisfaction
de votre clientèle parce qu'on a sorti
les chiffres en tableaux on voit
l'évolution de la satisfaction des
patients à sainte justine en 2010 à 1
sur 2 étaient satisfaits de ce qu'ils
mangeaient maintenance et 97% ça frôle
la perfection
oui exactement puis je vous dirais que
dans le mois dernier on a refait un
sondage on en 2019 et on a à peine le 99
pour ça on ne croyait pas oui tout à
fait tout à fait incroyable
donc il fallait à être audacieux
premièrement pour faire ça dans un
hôpital j'imagine le devait prendre le
le modèle d'un restaurant ou d'un hôtel
transposer ça dans un centre hospitalier
est ce que ça prend aussi davantage de
moyens est ce que ça coûte plus cher pas
du tout on était capable de faire ce
service là avec le même personnel en
cuisine ce que ça lui a demandé si une
modification au niveau des installations
mais à saint justin on était rendu à une
étape où on devait moderniser la cuisine
alors ça a été fait dans la
modernisation de l'établissement savez
vous si à d'autres hôpitaux québec qui
font la même chose au québec ou au
canada
le chemin au début tu es un service
d'hôtellerie qui hybride qui est pas là
mais nécessairement la même liberté que
nous mais ce qu'ils souhaitaient c'était
de faire un début dans ce virage
comment ça se passe dans le milieu est
ce que vous avez des questionnements
d'autres hôpitaux qui veulent imiter ce
que vous faites est ce que vous avez des
questions de la part des autorités des
autres hôpitaux il ya des centres site
alix onu nous visiter pour essayer de
comprendre un petit peu de quelle façon
ça fonctionnait à sainte justine
je pense que ce qui est important pour
les milieux c'est de vraiment prendre
conscience que c'est possible oui c'est
possible pour tous les centres
hospitaliers ce qui est important c'est
de réaliser dans le fond que c'est un
changement de culture au sein
d'établissements
alors ça serait pas un deux semaines
nous ça nous a pris quelques années
parce que toutes les parties prenantes
de l'hôpital ont été impliqués que ce
soit le personnel soignant
notre personnel les nutritionnistes les
professionnels c'était hyper important
parce que ça change la façon de
communiquer avec le patient maintenant
les infirmières doivent informer le
passé ainsi il
un examen à passer que le patient ne
peut pas commander parce que nous
maintenant c'est pas ça qui décide quand
il mange à oui c'est alors oui et puis
c'est toujours adaptée à ses besoins
nutritionnels parce que fort à pics et
des enfants il pourrait commander un peu
ce qu'ils veulent n'importe quand mais
ils sont guidés par le personnel
soignant
tout à fait nous ce qui est important
c'est justin tu que ce soit une
technicienne en diététique qui puisse
prendre l'appel afin de pouvoir
personnaliser la diable et leurs repas
et bien entendu respecter les régimes on
est quand même un obstacle trop
spécialisés donc on a beaucoup de
pathologies ce qui veut dire beaucoup de
régimes alimentaires mais on a un
logiciel qui nous permet justement de
pouvoir respecter ces régimes là en
terminant ce que vous avez mesuré si un
impact sur la santé des patients la
mesure qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
réalisé que plus de 50% des suppléments
alimentaires qui ne sont plus consommer
les passants ce qu'ils mangent
maintenance et des aliments donc pour
nous c'est vraiment une réussite est un
succès on en est très fier des
félicitations josée lavoie merci au
cours des dix matin merci beaucoup de
nous avoir invités